hello
is this working
hello hello
oh i think this is working
i don't think anyone's here though
i think i [ __ ] it up
i'm gonna go get another [ __ ]
thing addison klieber
what's up buddy
it's working we're live i've been
talking into the mic this whole time i
don't know if anyone
saw it watching roast battle
nice
uh there's a great video louis j gomez
um
did a little thing
uh going live on some other video check
it out
this
try refresh
try going to my page and finding the
latest live stream
i got some pizza right here got some
voodoo donuts they made their presents
in uh
[ __ ]
you know in austin
portland
portland thing that they're now in
austin
so much love much respect to voodoo
donuts thank you for making austin such
a great place
um
i
am
chilling in my van my beautiful
beautiful van do i meditate no not
anymore i wish i did i need to start it
again but i write which is sort of
meditative so i count that as meditation
i just lay on my bed and write and i
love
uh
thinking about things do you do
yo yoga
yo yoga
do i do you
i do yoga um i love yoga
i do a lot of downward dog to fix my
neck i have a neck issue so
i uh try to fix my neck that way
i do a lot of downward dog
um
and stuff
uh how are you so calm probably because
i
don't like being anxious or something
i like
being chill
chillness is
very very
valued by me
also like i'm sometimes too chill where
like things will happen and i should be
more energetic and i'm not so sometimes
i wish i was less chill
it's a blessing and a curse
hello hello hello hello
still doing that thing
turn that off
maybe it's with the zoom
hello
um
i'm not high at all thanks for asking
my
my
um
my
toxicology report would come back pretty
normal
i'm not very high
uh i'm actually pretty sober the only
thing i had to
uh alter my consciousness today was a
lone star which is like the pbr of texas
um
so i had a lone star at 9 00 pm it's 1
32 am right now that's the only thing i
had man i've been a good boy today i've
been my body is pure as the
conservatives would want i'm a christian
today i've only had the approved drug
alcohol
are you asian
yes
unfortunately i look high
unfortunately there's nothing i can do
about that i'm always going to look like
this maybe i've smoked so much weed
that
i'm just permanently looking like this
all the time
let's just get rid of that
little
bar
um i'm doing good i
had a good episode i think the latest
episode that came out on youtube was one
of my worst sets and so i'm glad to
have redeemed myself
in some degree to some degree hopefully
um in the next two weeks that's the
thing it's like it comes out two weeks
later so it's like by the time you guys
see it i've already processed and
rejected that part of myself
how is van life van life is amazing i
love it i love the freedom uh joe rogan
has [ __ ] you money i have a [ __ ] you van
i don't have the money to be able to say
[ __ ] you to people but i do have the van
to physically transport myself away from
people
where paige at i uh am not with her
we're not seeing each other anymore it
was a very messy breakup and she's
wherever the [ __ ] she is
are you sitting in a van streaming this
video yes i am sitting in a van
streaming this video
look at me
i'm in a van there's my ac
this is a good angle
it's hard to see
the tv and
look at the camera at the same time
look at that
there's a whole neighborhood out there
this is where my friend lives riley
the bernie sanders joke
oh oh so lopez remembers my bernie
sanders joke
okay honestly that joke did not get a
lot of good reactions in the live
audience
but it's one of my favorites because i'm
an incel
and
i love blaming women for me not getting
laid
but honestly i should uh work harder to
get laid i think it's an important thing
are you writing new jokes we're waiting
well listen to the podcast
the kill tony podcast how did you end up
on joe rogan's show i never have been on
his show
unfortunately what kind of van it's a
sprinter van
uh hi top what kind of engineering did
you study at georgia tech mechanical
engineering
uh where's my snow bunny
what
that was sexist i mean
it's inherently
sexist because
he's talking about sex
you know it's genders
i mean
is there a gender at fault are we
going to blame genders are we going to
blame socioeconomic conditions that make
men so unattractive because they're
financially destitute
and unable to live
uh
in a good way
who's that guy watching us in the corner
where is there a guy in the corner
are you talking about
this guy
cody johnston
um
beto for governor
beto
celedon
is
a dude up there but then beto i mean i
guess he's better than a conservative in
my opinion
because i'm a
little bit of a liberal hell hans i saw
you on sixth street once and asked if
you're a chinese sorry i was drunk um i
mean as far as sex street interactions
go that's pretty pretty tame pretty
normal
if you guys aren't familiar sixth street
is like
uh the party street it's just rows and
rows of bars on one street and then they
close off the street
um
anyone else hearing that [ __ ]
tap it buzzing
all right man keep wasting your talent
on kt until your juice runs out
okay well kill tony is the only reason
you guys are all here so i don't i
wouldn't say i'm wasting my talent on
kill tony
uh photo of a face in the top corner of
the door
oh
that's my boy
that's my boy bs
bernie
sanders he got ratioed by elon musk but
you know
he's like 70 years old he just he's not
good with technology he doesn't have to
win on that front he's still my man fbi
has hans vans
bugged i wish
then i could pick up some good audio and
do podcasts constantly static but not
too bothersome good
i'd rather uh live in a van than our
hometown seattle well i lived in a van
in seattle for a little bit i didn't
mind it seattle is actually a great town
for van life
that is so so annoying
uh sales is a good time for van life
because it doesn't get too hot or too
cold it's actually the perfect weather
because heat is the worst heat you need
to plug in because ac is like a [ __ ]
heat is easy to provide
so it's better to be in slightly colder
temperatures
honestly i wouldn't have been here
during the summer in texas i was only
supposed to be here two or three months
but then
i had to become a regular on kill tony
ugg
and then i was like i'm staying here
[ __ ] this is my new home can't get
rid of me
so then i stayed here for the summer i
was gonna leave i was gonna go to la
which would have been bad but not as bad
as texas
texas is [ __ ] brutal man in the
summer in a van
it's no joke but there's so many van
comedians here it's crazy everyone lives
in their car here it's really beautiful
uh hey hans do asians like peanut butter
what the [ __ ] do asians like peanut
butter i mean we're human
uh peanut butter is a food stuff it
provides us with calories necessary to
survive so it's not like we hate it but
it's not a big part of our culture you
don't go to asian restaurants and see a
lot of peanut butter inspired dishes
um although i'm sure they exist
i guess like [ __ ] vietnamese or thai
food has a lot of peanut butter in it
um
ever seen a tornado in texas no
peanut do asians like peanut butter
i mean it's like you're talking about us
like we're dogs
do you like peanut butter
it's of course
was that a fart no it's my [ __ ]
i think it's my
zoom h6 [ __ ] up
uh i should take care of it better
but should be in order lots of peanut
butter dishes peanut butter chicken
okay i'm not that familiar with asian
stuff i've been in america too long hi
hans do you remember me ryan park
uh there's two ryan parks that i've uh
run into in my life one ryan park was a
like
a beautiful brown skinned
uh half korean man who was like six foot
four
um
strong arms great chest
i remember that ryan park and then
there's another ryan park who's went to
my korean church and he
was uh
a little bratty little child i was very
much older than him and
he's very very adorable adorable child
so i don't know if it's that ryan park
or the other ryan park
i'm not high uh this is just what i look
like
um
it's just who i am i permanently look
high
so it's a super power
um because then it's like i'm always
like this
um
zulker brewery is this a van stream it
is a van stream let me turn around and
show you my messy bed
there's my drawing by styler styles
there's all my stickers and [ __ ]
there's my closet
there's my amazon package with my new
sure microphone in it
there's the battery power thingy
my bad katan
i put my katan board with all my
podcasting equipment so when i use when
i podcast i have to
uh
take that out so that's why it's out i
don't just always have it out there's my
shitty little
roof van
there was a leak so the [ __ ] paneling
got wet and all soggy and now the nail
won't hold the [ __ ]
fan [ __ ] cover up so i had to duct
tape it but hey looks ugly it works
though
it's good good enough right now i
patched the hole it doesn't leak anymore
there's the world map that i really like
although it's covered all the time by
all my [ __ ]
uh and this is uh where i jerk off a lot
i put my phone right there
and then
my penis goes like right around there
and i
jerk it
until i'm happy
until all my feelings go away
okay
there we go
katan that's kind of lame thought you'd
be a boggle guy i don't even know what
boggle is katan has uh legitimacy
within the nerd community so that's
important
um
[Music]
it's a playable game it's a game that's
good at being a game
uh you can play it you can do it well
and you can be skilled at it and it's
just just a good game it's just a good
time
um
so
what made you want to start comedy
it all began in the year
2012 or something 13 14.
i wanted to start comedy because i was
just done with school mechanical
engineering and
i got a 2.6 or 2.7 gpa i wasn't really
good at it
it's a very difficult thing to do and i
just didn't know what it was going to be
used for what i was learning this for
why i was doing it it's very interesting
fluid dynamics physics
you know statics
all learning about [ __ ] one half mv
squared you know
other things
um
i don't know what's going on with this
but i got a internship and then i got a
startup job
working at the startup company for
minimum wage and
surgical
device manufacturing and it's just like
i was just doing the normal thing living
life and it's like i don't want to do
this i don't want to live a normal life
we already do
know what happens when you live a normal
life get a white picket fence have a
wife
plop out two children we already know
what happens we know what our parents
lives were like
uh okay relax whatever whatever okay i'm
telling you someone asked me a question
um
and then so i was like i don't want to
live that life i want to live a life
of
adventure and fun and then i was
listening to a lot of joe rogan podcast
and joe rogan was talking about comedy
like it's a meritocracy like you work
hard at it and you get rewarded for your
hard work so that's what i was attracted
to and it's an art form so you could i
could be creative in it and um
and you could make money off of it it
was very monetizable art form unlike
you know
graffiti painting
uh or i don't know something else it's
just like you're in a room with people
you can charge those people to come in
it's like you can get money from it so i
thought it was just a
just a great jre will steer you wrong
well i mean
we're here because of jre
in more ways than one
my friend died today
can you say we love you brad for a
really cheap memorial tune thanks in
advance you rock ons game
we love you brad
open your eyes
have you taken your daily dose of
ivermectin
um
i actually have a sponsorship with ivy
drip
pretty saying
that do you want kids
of course
who doesn't want children i think if you
say you don't want children you're lying
we're all set up for children we're all
made
to pop out little versions of ourselves
how do i pee
oh good question
creep though
this is r.i.p
and sueno max
it's a mexican pea
you gotta pee like a mexican
uh i use detergent bottles i go to
the uh [ __ ] laundromats and
[ __ ]
get one of these because they already
have soap in it so they're already like
the first couple
batches are self-cleaning then after
that it becomes a little hazardous but
aren't asians only allowed one kid
that's china
in the 80s and 70s while they were going
through their industrial revolution and
actually that's not really what's
happening
um
thank you aaron lorick for ten dollars
hans kim let's effing go
okay
thank you man
i will effing go
i'm gonna move to the other side of the
street after this
before i go to sleep
shout out the gripers please that's some
internet [ __ ] how close to joe rogan are
you
i mean i'm in the same city as them he
lives like in the burbs
and i'm like in the ghetto
uh we're pretty far away
um physically shout out to groipers hans
you're more than welcome to come try to
come by to clean your clothes for free
anytime thank you man
i always say yes i always
accept those offers because you never
know when i'm when i'm gonna need it
because i live in a [ __ ] whatever in
a van ascension court i am extensioned
up right now
i could do this totally non-extensioned
up but it's just like i don't want to
use my battery if i don't have to are
you open to mix black kids
yeah i mean if they want to come in my
van i'm open to them black mixed black
kids are totally welcome in my van
i have lots of candy
candy van do you always kiss people on
stage i went to vulcan and you kissed
the singer with the band playing
okay
that was a dude and i did kiss him but
it was just a bit it's not like
something i have to do all the time i'm
trying not to like [ __ ]
be so horny all the time it's really
affecting my [ __ ] this is uh some voodoo
donuts courtesy a star one day keep it
up brother thank you
i am trying to keep it up i'm trying not
to let it drop
bro is lit on six get them voodoo you
ever get an apartment i'll be your
roommate i would love to get an
apartment as soon as i get a steady
income and
reliable steady income i will but i mean
until then i'm gonna live in a van save
up you know
uh be economically free financially free
do whatever i want han starbucks
internet is cutting out oh yeah the
[ __ ] obs just said it was [ __ ]
whatever
hopefully it's fixed now have you been
having fun in texas yes it's really
affecting your [ __ ]
uh the donut
you know that's the good thing about the
internet they're always connecting dots
together they're like oh this thing
happened and nothing happened that there
must be related and that's a lot of
comedy is just putting together two
things that shouldn't be together
uh
join us says beto
beto has been here from the beginning
[Music]
of
you ever been here you want to come over
to melbourne australia sure
i will
i'll go to australia who doesn't want to
go to australia
oh yeah
i love australia
i'm not gonna do that anymore
uh if you like this video dislike it i
mean i can't even see the dislikes
anyways so
that's just gonna tell the youtube
overlords to keep me more underground
until i actually blow up so thank you so
much for
keeping me underground have you ever
performed in jacksonville florida yes i
have i performed that mad dogs or mud
dogs
i met my friend jessica meers i saw my
friend jessica meers there met a lot of
funny people there beautiful beautiful
place that was right before the pandemic
literally like march
something i was in jacksonville doing my
little road trip i did a road trip from
new york city to miami i hit
richmond i had atlanta i hit washington
dc i hit philadelphia it was an epic
road trip and then right when i hit
miami boom boom boom boom boom all the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] was shutting down as i was getting
to miami it was like indiana jones and
then i spent some time in the everglades
waiting for everything to rain dogs is
what i mean yes thank you
um
and uh it was a it was a great
experience to be in miami but i wanted
to get out of miami because i was
looking at a map and it's like i'm here
and i'm stuck if things shut down over
here
i can't i don't have anywhere to move so
i went to seattle which is also sort of
in the corner but
you know
it's less cornerish but yeah i went all
the way from miami to seattle then from
seattle i stayed there about seven eight
months just
mooching off my parents collecting
unemployment and food stamps accruing i
got so rich during that time and then i
went down to los angeles
and plied my craft there
have you met any big celebs anyone
interesting yeah ron white joe rogan
tony hinchcliffe
um
others ari shaffer mark normand shane
gilles shingilis is so nice he's like
brewing he's brewing me up
he's like
he
is he's so nice even though it's like
i'm so beneath him he's like treating me
like an equal yellow rose or red rose
while living in the van
uh who has hotter babes i mean
it's it's really like
i don't know
i actually haven't been to the red rose
i've been to the yellow rose um but who
has the hotter babes
i i think they're both all very
attractive i was there last monday
yesterday technically two days ago i
guess now but
there were some asian
women there
and i uh thought they were very
attractive i don't want to go up to them
and be like hey do you work at the red
rose
and they'd be like excuse me are you
calling me a stripper
and that'd have been super offensive
it's like calling a woman who's fat
pregnant so i didn't do that how did you
feel about norm mcdonnell dying how did
i feel about it i kind of felt like this
kind of felt sad about that
i mean who knew that he was [ __ ]
you know really sad
uh he was who had cancer the whole time
shingles seems cool he's really cool
speed this up dude
no big celeste what do you want me to do
how do you want me to speed it up
faster
how did you feel about west virginia nor
mcdonald is great i really liked him he
he was a
very very legendary comedian who
slayed with such little energy i mean
not little energy but just so efficient
with it and it was just like so
so powerful because it wasn't about like
how much energy he put in it's about
like his mind and like
you could go higher intellectually
there's a higher ceiling
would you do a podcast with cosby
five dollars from james s thank you did
you start purely with open mic
or where did you learn comedy i did
start purely with open mic i actually do
a lot of open mic still which
uh pisses off some of my more famous
friends who want better for me but i
just love open mics open mics are my
bread and butter
which is kind of sad but those grumpy
comedians i love talking to them they
don't know it but i'm using them and i
just i just love just
going up there and just [ __ ] all
over them it's like there whenever you
do something it's like you're always
like uh being vulnerable if you're being
too grumpy that's a lot of energy you're
being vulnerable if you're in a good
mood and happy then you're not as
vulnerable but you're also easy to get
left so whatever the situation is
you can always get a laugh and you can
always work
you can always work it and i love
applying my shitty jokes in front of
them and working it out and figuring out
what works and trying to make it
make it good good morning from ptpt
i don't know what ptpt is
[ __ ] it thailand
what's your favorite way to write a joke
that's a great question most people are
like how do you write a joke what do you
do to write a joke but what's my
favorite way to write a joke
my favorite way to write a joke
is to like
uh
notice something stupid someone is doing
and then call them out on it and be like
man what an idiot this guy is he just
did this and this and that's stupid for
this this and this reason and everyone's
like
you're right you're so smart and funny
hanzo i love you and i'm like whoa i
really like this feeling let me try to
recreate this on stage and then i
recreate it on stage and it works that's
my favorite way
pt is portugal damn
how do i not know this
uh portugal is cool
my friend
mata leong i love brazil i i'm from
brazil and i love to
shave my pubic hair really really short
hey hans what's your thoughts on going
to thailand for dental work thanks
champion what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you saying about any
teeth
um
i'm really sensitive about my teeth and
i would love to get cheap dental work
i'd also love to
uh get some lip work in thailand some of
those hookies hookers
um do i like kanye yes i love kanye
what's that song
um
he has a really good song that i really
like homecoming is good i like his older
stuff i don't like his newer stuff i
think he's gone a little off the deep
end but uh that's not news to anyone not
ladyboys
uh women
have you considered eyelid surgery yes i
would love to get eyelid surgery
i'd also like to get the chin surgery
so that i can have like an underbite
um but in the future
i'm gonna look like this
and you guys are gonna recognize me i'm
gonna be much better looking i'm gonna
have like a normal shaped face
and normal shaped eyes
i'm just gonna be a completely different
person it's gonna be great
do i own any bitcoin no not yet
kanye loves kanye more than i do
uh you should just walk around with your
hands like that oh my god that is not a
sustainable solution how am i gonna eat
pizza or do anything you want round eye
uh
yeah sure i'll take round eye
you seem like your fans are mostly
online
do you worry about repeating the same
jokes too much have you seen i've seen a
lot of the stuff on kill tony repeated
in your joe rogan warm up love you i
don't really warm up worry about it i
mean that's how the art form progresses
i write jokes as fast as i can
i see other comedians and i see how fast
they write jokes i'm not slower than
them
i think this is just how
comedy works and
it sucks now because you guys have to
listen to the same jokes over and over
again but um
i think that in the long run
people
are gonna
be like
wow they're look at all this
stuff
hopefully i'm just
i don't know this is all i can do
um
i i want to write more i want to write
more yes i want to write a bit every day
and i want to be funny every day i know
joe rogan writes a new hour every year
and i'm not at that pace yet and i hope
to be one day but i don't want to rush
it he took years to get to that level so
i want to take my time and become like
him i'm a protoss guy
i'm in my van yes
uh what are your thoughts on the boto
league massacres i don't know what the
boto league massacres are let me google
that
real quick
league massacre
was a massacre war crime against
communists and suspected sympathizers
that occurred in summer of 1950 during
the korean war
estimates of the death toll very
60 thousand to a hundred ten thousand to
two hundred thousand
damn
i mean war as hell
i don't know if you know this
i've been through a couple myself
i've been through the war of
open mics
uh yeah i mean obviously not good
you shouldn't
kill people i think that uh killing
people should be avoided because every
one of those lives had
a potential to contribute to society and
it's just
you know thank you tj bligh for
hanging out
you're a bad korean for not knowing that
honestly
uh i don't feel that bad it's like
i uh i think that there's uh
there's a lot of good parts of korea
that i would rather focus on than the
massacres but yeah i do feel like uh
there was a very
right-wing authoritarian
uh dictatorship going on in korea and
there were protests every day and
students were murdered in korea and
um there was a harsh uh pushback against
communism and
because that was the enemies thing we
don't do that we do the other thing
uh so i think that was a little
little much i guess
i uh i think that back then human life
was cheaper too it was like get rid of
them
we don't care they don't invent
smartphones or have apps
they don't have uh cameras to record
their everyday thing did your
grandparents survive that massacre yes
my grandparents survived that massacre
in the 50s if they didn't i want to be
here
but my grandfathers
both of them have passed away uh
recently within the last decade
so they lived to a long healthy age
um my grandmothers are both alive
tons of hot chicks to make out with yeah
dude it's pretty crazy in here
uh but hey
maybe if you uh buy me a super chat i'll
let you come into the van
i'll lock the door let you spend some
time with some hot chick in here because
it's just so full of hot chicks champa
isn't making her teeth they are amazing
that's why i asked about the work in
thailand and you know you might have the
hook up love your champ thanks man i was
just kidding i was just being insecure
you know when i'm insecure it hurts my
friends and the people
that love me so it's like it's on me to
be
really really
not
insecure and try to be
try to be uh
confident so that
um my friends and loved ones can also
enjoy uh confidence instead of just
sadness for me
uh let's see if this helps
it's a little brighter
um
how many koreans died
in korean war
in the korean war
the article is very
optional in korean apparently how many
koreans died how many people died in
korean war
how many people died in korean war how
many people died in the korean war the
korean war
nearly five million people died pretty
smooth setup you got going on how was
the van powering all this equipment i
got an uh [ __ ] thing i got an
extension cord from my friend riley's
house
uh hopefully this is better lighting let
me know if it is any plans to be on
legion escanks yeah i plan to beg them
to be on legionness games i would
happily accept any opportunity to be on
that podcast i think the work that they
do is amazing and i hope that i can keep
up comedically
i hope that i can
quip
like dalton pruitt does dalton's very
good at that do you have any favorite
spots in san antonio yes i love
fitzgerald i played there recently i
performed there i did comedy there i did
stand up there recently i love
blind tiger
[ __ ] dope little spot in the basement
and of course lol comedy club i opened
up for jp sears there there's a face
above the curtain that's bernie sanders
he's the granddaddy of them all
um
[Music]
and uh
he's up there he's just chilling
he's just uh up there oh i gotta change
my name and picture or send dude fan
books ten bucks oh you don't have to
send me money please don't feel like
that's an obligation what kind of pizza
is behind you a pepperoni pizza from
hoboken pizza
uh
love it love sixth street loves humanity
love people gather together
in close quarters being efficient and
trading with each other and [ __ ]
doing things and you know like if
everyone's spread out it's like so much
less efficient like it's crazy like if
you go to the suburbs [ __ ] there's no
stores anywhere like
these rich people have to drive every
time they want to go get a stick of
chapstick why wouldn't you just stick a
store in there and they're [ __ ] giant
suburbs everything has to be houses you
don't you don't have one barber shop one
[ __ ] dry cleaner like it's all houses
like how is that ideal
like won't don't you want to live in
like a [ __ ] place where you can walk
around and [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know about uh
[ __ ] do i have tv yes i have a tv
i'm using it
um all right p joe rogan he passed the
cove hit tonight
can you imagine if covet could kill joe
rogan not even a liberal horde could
kill joe rogan joe rogan could take them
all in
mataleo and all of them do you feel like
you have
to be the smartest guy in the room to be
hilarious
um
no
i
don't i don't i think that's not
the right mentality
um
i think that um
if you're trying to be the smartest guy
that's like very uh competitive and it's
like you want to
coalesce the audience with yourself into
one big ball and go up together
uh and create one big beautiful thing
with them instead of just being like
we're gonna go
alone and i'm gonna be awesome and
you're gonna worship me
uh i think that's kind of perverse and i
think that uh
you should uh we should you should try
to make something beautiful together
instead of being better than them make
something like whatever
uh together tips for starting
in comedy beyond just go find a mic
thanks for great content
um tips for starting comedy beyond just
go
find a mic thanks for great content um
tips for comedy i would say
close your eyes
and have big teeth and a big chin
i would say
[ __ ] find out what you want to say
and what you think about the world and
what you think the world needs i mean
a lot of my political stuff is some of
my least funny stuff so maybe that's not
great advice
um but i would say
[Music]
just like find out what
what you want to say
and what you want to do
um because i've always enjoyed talking
to people in a group setting like i grew
up in schools where there's a teacher
talking public speaking then there's a
church where there's a pastor youth
pastor whatever bible study leader
doing public speaking it's a dynamic
that i'm very familiar with and that i
grew up observing and being a part of
and i've always wanted to be a part of
that
um yeah my eyes are open right now
um
but yeah i mean you gotta enjoy that
dynamic of an audience and speaker and
then like find out what
about that dynamic you find the funniest
what makes you laugh
in that scenario what makes you laugh in
any scenario i would say just write down
everything that makes you laugh and
within a day
everything that you find amusing
anything that you find interesting any
thoughts that you have that you think
are worth preserving write everything
down
um
so this guy says come to dallas you can
play my brewery i would love to i'm
going to dallas actually this thursday i
have a show there please come dallas
comedy club i'm gonna do a headlining
set 45 minutes so i hope you guys show
up there hanzo just got there did you
talk about this week's kill tony
here uh yes this week's kill tony i had
a good set apparently people told me i
had a good set so i'll take the word for
it who am i to deny them their
perspective
um
um
i uh i think that this set went better
than other sets of mine the ones that
the one that came out this monday i was
kind of disappointed in
i wish i did better it was one of my the
least good things that i did
on kill tony so far
but you know
stay tuned i got two more weeks coming
i've already processed that loss that
loss has already been
categorized in my head and rationalized
um
dallas thursday be there yes be there
dallas comedy club look it up rel
sanchez says hi they love you at nobody
hat nobody's happy podcast i love raul
raul is an og comedy guru he's my
comedy sensei
i
grew up i
i
hit the mics with them and i [ __ ]
applied my craft and cut my teeth and
sharpened my nails and
hardened my [ __ ]
and loosened my butthole and
scraped my knees alongside raul sanchez
in the streets of
new york city creek in the cave
uh doing mike's there every night
drinking two dollar pbrs good night hans
thanks goodnight richards
schmidt
maybe this is a good time to uh do a
podcast or do it whatever
uh because it's
whatever
the cac handsy nice oh guys give it a
rest he moved on from miss p
yeah guys no one cares about her anymore
the new girl is
i don't have a new girl i'm talking to
this new girl mimi
uh and then i also talked to this new
girl
uh
jubilee
how do you not assimilate into a banana
your industry is insanely pressurized is
that a rick and morty reference i don't
know banana all right not assimilated
into i don't understand that thank you
for the last hans you were still
classing the most recent kill tony thank
you i should not be insecure because
being insecure only hurts the people
around me
i had a good time and i did whatever i
could can i have paige's number
that's so funny
you're gonna
cat you're gonna uh
you're gonna capitalize on my
on my loss
wow so funny
you're gonna make me feel even shittier
uh what do you think of norman chain and
ari i think they're amazing
amazing amazing comedians some of the
funniest comedians in history in the
world and i got to share a green room
with them and watch them eat food it's
not mimi meyer it's someone else i don't
want to start a rumor um
we are the new girl in his life yeah i'm
youtubing and you know this is fun
i hope that this provides you guys with
with some benefit with some benefits
and i hope that it uh helps me
do whatever
i want to see the show in person i don't
know i hate that there's a 21 and up
rule in america it really stifles the
young creative talent that could be
playing the craft and learning uh
and i think that's not that helpful i
mean
we're cutting off the talent and you
know germany
and korea and china
has their 18 year olds doing whatever
they want going to bars and stuff so we
need to catch up with the rest of the
world and not have this [ __ ]
backwards 21 and up rule
um and not just because i want to [ __ ]
18 year olds
stevie weeby
funnier than bobby lee i mean what is
that's a matter of perspective but
they're both very funny people and i
love stevie weeby
i love his uh zany attitude
uh and i love bobby lee og comedy korean
guru god all respects to the motherland
bobby lee what's your korean name kim
hang
it's a wedja
it's only two syllables most korean
names are three ever heard of andrew
callahan with all guests no breaks sixth
street blues vibe would be a dope club
yes
i love andrew callahan
he's a genius he's only like 22 or
something and he like did too much acid
in high school and he's like i'm done
with
he's like already done been through it
and he's just like super super smart
uh you should bow when you meet bobby of
course
i am korean this that is the custom that
is definitely gonna happen riley is your
homie but is he really funny i don't
know you're a better solo actor
don't tell riley that but riley is super
funny and
he's
he's a he's a little sad but
but he's a good guy and he just needs to
get out there and hopefully i can
influence him to start doing more
comedy
how old are you hans 32
you ever watched macau brothers back in
the day with stevie
no i don't know what that is macau
brothers
i know the scissor sisters or whatever
he does
so he wasn't going on but who would you
consider doing a podcast hypothetically
oh my ideal uh podcast guest would be
william montgomery casey rocket i don't
know if you guys know casey rocket but
he's a phenom
um
[ __ ] there's so many dylan sullivan
the big old fatty
uh look at peng he was the second
funniest
what
how did you
really schedule a show with pengn
pandang
uh well
my friend uh victor had a show and then
i found out later that pang dang was
going to be on it and then i was like oh
that's kind of weird i'm i wonder what
that's going to be like and i didn't
really think it was going to be that big
a deal
thank you i can't really type in korean
opinion [ __ ] was a trip because he had
such a great set that night oh my god
don't say that
god damn it
um peng dang is a great great
[ __ ]
i'm back with paige again no i'm not
back with paige again stop asking about
paige she's gonna get mad at me
she's so mean
i mean so great
how do your parents feel about your
career choice they're just glad i'm not
a drugged out crack addict because they
were
a little little unsure of me in the
beginning they did not have a lot of
faith in me i got caught for shoplifting
in college and then i was suspended for
a semester so they were like oh no
please don't uh you know die or commit
crimes or live a life of crime and
comedy living a life comedy is like one
step up from a life of crime
have you tried lsd of course yes
so
you know it's like
it's like a better thing to do than
to
uh [ __ ]
live a degenerate life at least i have a
purpose and a focus and a craft that i'm
working towards what attracted you to
mechanical engineering honestly the only
reason i chose mechanical engineering is
because i went to georgia tech
and that was the best major at that
school
and i was like i don't want to go to the
school and choose like some random ass
major i'm gonna do what this school is
best at so that's why i chose it
what were you stealing i was stealing
everything i was going to pet stores and
stealing medicine for my stray dog that
i picked up i was stealing electric
shavers and selling them on ebay i was
stealing
um
food like meat i would steal meat i was
stealing bowls i was stealing everything
i needed anything that i could fit in my
jacket it's really a stupid thing to do
i mean it's fun
you got a cup how many times did you get
away with it i got away with it like at
least like 50 70 times i would go to
best buy i would go to walmart i would
just steal anything i could get my
little grubby little hands on but if you
really want to steal go put on a suit go
to a bank start stealing like a grown-up
don't go out there like a [ __ ]
caveman stealing things with your hands
this is [ __ ] america
this is not [ __ ]
you know i don't want to name a country
uh you're a necromancer
stealing food isn't steely
i like that mentality are you really on
the spectrum
actually i'm on the atnt that's a riley
gilmore joke shouts out to riley gilmore
do people think you are constantly 10
years younger than you actually are they
think i'm 27
so like five years younger which isn't
that much honestly i'm kind of offended
by the 27 i think i'm
like i don't have anything on my eyes
right now
sometimes i do
my forehead
is clear when i'm not trying to make my
eyes bigger artificially
uh would you rather get one million
dollars a year guarantee but you can
only tour with then
or
only ever be able to do
your minute on
easy kill tony definitely kill tony
uh
i don't need money i live in a van i'm
happy i don't want to sacrifice my soul
to tour with dan nanan who i am i'm i
think i can
burn bridges with that guy i don't think
i'll ever need anything from him you and
ari shafir can do a podcast about
stealing i love ari arya is like i think
we're very similar in very many ways
georgia tech gpa 2.67 and i don't even
give a [ __ ] that's a very bad gpa
homeboys love zhang labang
[Music]
2.9 gpa
i wish
uh so funny story is that for our
uh design class we had to design we had
to like cad something very difficult and
we chose the lamborghini murcielago and
then we just bought it online and we
just submitted it and then
my my room my partner did and then like
that was like the last class we took it
was like during my senior year second
semester we did that we cheated and we
just bought a cad model off the internet
and submitted that and then like i got
an email
like
one day before school officially ended
and like a week before graduation i was
like please come see me you two in my
office and i was like delete and then
and then i graduated so i don't i don't
know what happened
horrible choice the models are free this
was in 2011. i don't know what the
[ __ ]
seen as like hans why the [ __ ] are you
awake
because i'm a comedian and usually i'm
awake at this time because i have a lot
of adrenaline
from just doing shows and then i have to
stay up and just like
process what happened and eat and just i
i'm always up this late trevor noah said
that he went to sleep at like 5 a.m and
woke up at like 2.
so
i'm in good company
um trevonnua this great guy but i think
jon stewart is the og god damn jon
stewart came back and he's [ __ ] his
takes are so sharp and he's like
he when he's performing for the audience
he doesn't need the laugh the laughs
come
because of his brilliance but he's not
searching for it it doesn't change him
the laughs are just like
oh i need that but then he he's just so
depressed inside of himself that he's
just like centered within himself and he
just says exactly the correct things
because that's the only metric he has
it's not he's not changing himself for
the laughs he's trying to get the best
points across and i love that
and when i'll ever replace seth meyers
what the [ __ ]
do not compare seth meyers to uh to
jon stewart van tour please
is so [ __ ]
so [ __ ] hooked up my camera
what do you think of bilbert bill burr
uh oh gee
god of comedy
um bill burt is one of the best i just
listened to hassan abby reacts to bill
burr reacts to kyle rittenhouse and he
had a great take the
year ago a year ago when that [ __ ] first
happened so he's just like [ __ ] on
top of everything
um
do you trade crypto in your van
no i don't i don't want to get into that
it's just like the reason i don't get
into crypto is that i don't want to
dabble in it if i want to do it i
actually want to do it and if i'm going
to actually do it that's going to take
up a lot of time and if that takes up a
lot of time that's going to get in the
way of comedy so i just want to
specialize and focus on comedy if you're
looking for crypto advice go to a crypto
guy you know i'm just going to be doing
the comedy thing it's not like something
i want to get good at like i don't want
to get good at staring at numbers i
don't think that's
going to make me a better person i think
that makes me a better robot or whatever
but i'm interested in things that will
make me a better person and i don't
think sitting in front of a computer
waiting for numbers to go up will
necessarily make me
uh
that much better as a person
um but if you can make money off crypto
i think that's awesome because
um then you can escape wage slavery and
live your own life and do whatever the
[ __ ] you want
i should ask for bitcoin instead of
dollar pay from rogan i am not asking
rogan for anything he gives me whatever
he wants if if he wants to give me a
[ __ ] tissue for opening for him i'll
[ __ ] take the tissue
um
where's your nft dropping i actually
have an nft i posted a story about it
when it first happened but i don't know
what happened to it tell us about the
evolution of your best joke
my best joke i think
i don't want to think about my jokes as
having a best or worst but
i like i like my redneck joke and the
evolution of that joke was
i have no idea i think i started saying
that joke exactly the way i'm saying it
now so it didn't really evolve like i
don't really
um
i don't really
evolve that joke that much i just
started saying it and then i was like
wow this is a
well-written joke let me not change
anything about it and i've been saying
it the same way for 17 years now
uh tell us about past drugs
um past drug experiences i took acid and
got beat up by the cops
i was high on acid running around
seattle with my friends and i didn't
want to go in my friend's house because
i thought there was termites in the air
and then i went for a drive
and
um
the car that i had back then was so
weird because it would always fog up no
matter what
so it was really foggy my friend was
stepping on the door and i thought it
was a homeless person so i just took off
and then i started hallucinating while i
was on the road it was like a full-on
hallucination i've never tripped that
hard again i kind of want to take acid
and go for a drive because that [ __ ]
worked that made me hallucinate like a
[ __ ] i was not
in that car which is dangerous as [ __ ]
but
it was a great trip in that way
i thought i was a housewife running away
from my abusive husband i thought i was
on a road trip with my friends and all
my friends were in there it was like i
was dreaming but i was awake and it was
a really cool experience
but then a cops
got me and then
they did not treat me very well like
like not even an ounce of kindness not
even like a gesture of like you're safe
now we got you they're like annoyed that
they have to do their [ __ ] job this
is your [ __ ] job take care of the
people you [ __ ] idiots
um but yeah i was a high on acid so i
deserved to be beaten to a pulp and
tasered and pepper sprayed for 10
minutes
um
did you grow up rich middle class what
were your high school friends like i
grew up
upper middle class i was probably
close to upper class
i lived in a nice house in clyde hill
washington
in high school my dad was a
mathematician for microsoft he made good
money he makes good money now apparently
although i don't see too much of it
[Music]
yeah my friends in high school were very
chill like they were losers i was a
loser they were losers we were all
hanging out as losers it was beautiful i
loved it i don't want to want to be a
cool guy because then you stop thinking
then you stop growing
uh so we were always scrambling trying
to figure things out do you like the
nether hour i love the nether hour
they're my favorite they're such good
guys and i love their music i just want
to hang out with them more have you ever
been to whidbey island yes i don't
really remember it though how long did
it take for you to try acid again
probably like a month later i really
didn't let that affect me it's i
did not blame myself for the drug at all
i blame the police 100 for their inhuman
behavior
um but
you know
it's like
i i have faith in myself and
i don't know if that happens again i
know i can survive it although it won't
be pleasant um
but
it made me stronger because i knew what
i could stand up to and that i didn't
break in that moment maybe the acid
helped but the they were trying to like
[ __ ] with me and torture means it was
really weird
have you ever been gay for a day
i've been gay for pay but not for a day
just probably two hours seen page lately
seen page lately seen page lately
if you can recommend one book what would
it be
uh
sex at dawn by christopher ryan
because
i love
i love his perspective and how he has
like
he has an innate sense of what's right
and wrong and like
he wants us to get closer to something
more beautiful
in the world
are you really asian or is it the
lasting effects of pepper spray
um i'm really asian
the pepper spray wore off um
but the taser
has prolapsed my prolapsed my anus and
now i'm just [ __ ] all over the place
what music
the music that i really like is
uh indie
uh alternative
i like
bluegrass i love
i love nice little chill vibes
that's hot hell yeah
uh so you basically live in a van by
choice your parents got that money
yeah well i mean i can't really access
that money
um i do live in a van by choice i love
living in a van and
start posting some of your standard
clips on it goes crazy where i can bring
in so many fans for you i mean i tried i
put some [ __ ] up there it never does too
well but i'll keep doing it don't worry
i won't give up i won't get discouraged
we should go to mars for a year for
comedy what the [ __ ] what kind of comedy
clubs are on mars why would it why would
that be comedic
um i love traveling and all that
but i don't know it's hard to bring back
that experience unless you're doing
comedy every day
and figure out what it says
i don't speak your [ __ ] language
did acid change your personality
hopefully
hopefully it didn't make me
more boring hopefully made me more fun
and
better than all these suburban sober
dumbasses
so yes i hope it did change my
personality you're the man have a good
night see ya james wong
what are good open mics in seattle
seattle has changed so much ever since i
left i left like four years ago
and
i really lost my time in seattle seattle
was a good city this beautiful city
right now i have no idea the pandemic
[ __ ] everything up in seattle because
everyone there was hanging on by a
thread they didn't really want to be
doing comedy and a lot of them quit or
stop doing shows
[Music]
because they're liberals
they're weak
um
do you recommend van life yes i
recommend van life i think it'll make
you tougher so get ready for that
um i think van life is great because it
frees you from wage slavery and you
work for yourself and you
buy yourself a home instead of buying
one on the free market which can be
manipulated to make you work more than
is actually worth
uh
about my dear what what happened dear
joe rogan did he really die i'm not
gonna believe that
i don't i don't think joe rogan died
how much does it cost he did he did a
show tonight he sold out the vulcan
but what's your favorite movie you've
seen this year probably dune i loved
dune
uh if you didn't like it that means you
probably
don't understand what it's like to be
the son of a duke and also be the son of
a bene jesuit
dude the two combinations of those two
things that it makes that guy so
powerful it's like how could you not
respect that power wouldn't you want to
be
a son of like
all that masculine power of
you know monarchy and feudalism or
whatever nobility and also the womanly
feminine power
that timothy chalamet has
a [ __ ]
uh
[ __ ] uh
reading minds and convincing people to
do things by talking like this
my favorite austin open mic would
probably have to be one at the creek the
creek has just such a good vibe it's
like almost like
neglected so that nobody knows it but
it's like there's some good comedy
happening there that nobody
nobody will see
nobody will ever know
all right i gotta go
i'm way way
i'm not used to talking this long
i need to fix my
[ __ ] respiratory tract or something
i wish i had a water bottle here
good day good day from australia
head in the background is bernie sanders
i've been over this already welcome to
the stream
wherever i'm coming here right now yeah
yeah little voice on people
yes
subscribe to my channel
like everything
i am a banana jazzer at sun
boo the jew
asians are sort of jewish i identify
with jewish how do you get big during
the sensitive area
what how did he get big during the
sensitive era
oh during the sensitive era
oh how do i get big just uh wait for
tony hinchcliffe to bring you up into
fame
that's what i did um you know
it's like troubling times and stuff
all right thank you guys good night
love you